thank you andrew tay i'm gonna take a
big foot and stick in
don't even with me bro
it's purple and nine inches long
show
bitmex the og crypto derivatives
platform and the best place to buy your
bitcoin
everybody has been sending me this video
of new yorkers reacting to andrew tate
so this is my video reacting to new
yorkers reacting to andrew tate before i
get into it this video is sponsored by
the og crypto derivatives exchange
bitmex so bitmex actually offer many
different cryptocurrencies including
bitcoin so if you do want to grab some
bitcoin while the market is down while
the price of bitcoin is down then pick
bitmex as your go-to cryptocurrency
exchange i'm gonna leave all the links
for you in the description below also
don't forget to hit the subscribe button
and the like button so you never miss a
video all right let's go asking people
about andrew t i
hate that guy if you are listening and
you see you are weird
trafficker is a bald
i love how they call him a sex
trafficker and they've never even met
him these girls already with all the
swearing and the shouting already come
across as low value girls i mean why's
had trousers undone i agree i have to
agree with that everybody who likes
anderson they're just weird how do you
feel about the fact that he has like a
lot of fans and he's the most searched
man on the internet right now and he has
a lot of impressionable young fans that
actually believe that this is the way to
be a man i honestly hate that especially
with like new men you know like i have a
baby cousin and like he has a pretty
misogynistic father like he doesn't
respect women i'd love to see her
definition of what misogynistic means
thank god for his mom i want to teach
him how to respect women especially she
wants to teach him how to respect women
yeah she's walking around with her
trousers undone okay you don't respect
yourself a man who sleeps with 200 women
is the man a woman who sleeps with 200
men is worthless yeah i know i give he
sounds like he sucks
have you noticed how the men that don't
like andrew tate are always like
overweight and feminine looking like why
is this guy got earrings in and a belly
we're asking people about andrew tate
he's a he has some interesting takes
women are property what do you think
about that
i'm gonna assume he doesn't like it
let's see if i'm right this is a person
this is yes this is andrew tate this is
disgusting it's a disgusting mentality
i knew it i've already spoken about this
many times when andrew talks about women
being men's property i don't actually
think it's supposed to be anything
misogynistic it's supposed to mean he
has responsibility over her because he's
paying for everything he's looking after
her fact that these human beings exist
and it's gross and it's awful andrew
tate's a weird man firstly before they
even speak these people have cloths and
nappies over their faces so i'm just not
gonna take what they say seriously but
let's see if they have anything actually
useful to say the guy that probably has
mommy issues
and he probably got hurt but you don't
see other guys doing that they move on
with their lives another thing he says
is that men build everything you see
around you women built nothing so
they're places at home and cooking so i
think the interview is actually taking
andrew out of context firstly i agree
men did build everything it's the men
that built the roads the bridges the
skyscrapers they're the ones that dig in
the mines men built everything and i
don't even think andrew's saying her
place is at home it's just that women
have a different role it's not that
offensive it's not that bad i'm not even
gonna lie but like
men be starting wars
men be messing everything in the [ __ ] up
look at the stick well men also be
fighting wars to protect freedom men
also be running into burning houses to
save women and children but okay yeah
men be fighting wars let's keep going
whatever you see around you was built by
men women built nothing their places at
home cooking
well i'd rather be at home
there you go a woman who actually says
the truth do you know why she says the
truth that she'd rather be at home
cooking because she's older and she's
experienced life and she's been out
there she's done the work and she's like
nah i just want to be a housewife it's
only the younger girls that have these
toxic aggressive opinions because they
don't really know any better
is there anything there i'm gonna
[ __ ] find you out thank you andrew
i'm gonna take a
[Music]
i don't know if you caught what this
woman said she literally just threatened
to rape andrew tate
imagine if he did that are we gonna
cancel this girl is this toxic
femininity she literally just threatened
to rape andrew that's disgusting i've
never heard andrew ever threaten to
abuse a woman so funny how it's okay for
a woman to say this or a girl to say
this but not a man the double standard
here is strong i think that he one is
just promoting a lot of harmful
stereotypes and violence towards like
just
women and also her friend literally just
promoted violence towards a man but okay
like non-binary people because i can't
even mark she just said non-binary
people i can't take her seriously from
here onwards i don't know what he thinks
about that i think he's an angry
closeted gay
well that was kind of homophobic this is
really toxic these girls are literally
everything they're accusing andrew of he
has some interesting takes on women and
i want you guys to just tell me what you
think they're wearing masks again
nappies on their faces this is gonna be
interesting i think he's a little boy
who has never i've had gotten a piece
in his entire life and in fact he
actually has a lot of women but it's not
consensual how does she know that it's
not consensual she's just accused a man
of rape these women are insane actually
said that a man who cries the woman
that's with him is ugly and fat so she's
with him because he cries a real woman
would be with a man that doesn't cry
because like what the like men have
feelings too why is he putting out this
message
this is the truth about the dynamics
between men and women if she's with a
man that's crying on her shoulder all
day behaving weak she's going to lose
respect for him and she's going to dump
his ass but women don't want to admit
that
it's that
alpha male like can we like forget about
that no it's what you want as a woman
you want an alpha male god i wish women
would be more um
self-aware
and realizing everyone's human do you
know who andrew says hey
it's the girl right there that's my boy
yeah who don't know who that is you're
you're a different take now because
everybody here was like really angry
towards them so tell me what you think
about why they angry he's speaking
finally
why are you going finally the brother
speaks the truth yeah this guy's cool
let's find out why he likes andrew tate
cause he's telling you to treat me like
a king and you want to be treated like a
queen but yeah i want to treat a man
like a king i want to honor a man and
treat him like a king but i need a
strong man an alpha i can only treat an
alpha like a king like the girl said
before she wants a man that's crying on
her shoulder all day no you don't you're
not going to treat him like a king
i don't understand what's wrong with
society today i know what's wrong with
society feminism
it's made women masculine entertain i'm
not gonna lie you said you was gonna get
jake paul of bugatti you know what i'm
saying i'm looking for bugatti if you
want to give me a call you know i'm
saying it could be a honda 2018 you know
what i'm saying ex i think andrew must
get this guy bugatti i think anybody
that stands by andrew tay deserves a
lambo or a bugatti 100 when he's getting
to the bugatti club all right i think
i've had enough of this video everybody
is super woke there's too many masks
it's annoying me sort of like giving me
a headache these aggressive angry women
i get why men don't like angry women to
be honest i think this interviewer is
actually really biased this guy hates
andrew he didn't even press anyone he
didn't even ask them to give any
examples so i feel like i've just wasted
a few minutes of my life all right i
think i need to get back to bitcoin this
is literally giving me a headache if you
want to see more of this content hit the
subscribe button and hit the like button
so you stay up to date the leia hill
plan show
you